he was the smiling face of NBA
basketball for two decades Kobe bean
Bryant dribbled and scored with the
formidable Los Angeles Lakers his entire
career his death has shocked fans from
around the world many say his influence
expands beyond just the basketball court
this is more than basketball
it was it was just the mentality to get
through life and he's got me through so
many struggles in my life it's one of
the hardest losses I've ever dealt with
I've never even met the man so 45 years
of living I have not felt this much
grief in love for one man Bryant was a
shooting guard for the LA Lakers he went
straight from high school to the NBA he
was an 18 time all-star who won five NBA
titles and two Olympic gold medals only
forty-one years old he died alongside
his 13 year old daughter Gianna his
daughter also showed on court talent and
was aiming to follow her father's
footsteps into professional basketball
he even credited Gianna after winning an
unexpected Oscar in 2018 my daughter
gave me the best piece of advice I was a
little worried about turning us into a
film that never done that something like
that before
and we were in a house and we were
talking about as a family and my little
11 you or Gianna goes well dad you
always tell us to go after our dreams so
man up she's 11 man oh so I had to man
up and go for it
Brian and his wife had four daughters
and after retiring in 2016 he became a
vocal advocate for female sports
even outside of sports people around the
world are mourning the loss of a
longtime icon more in the story I'm
joined here in the studio by a Lima
hotaki from DW sports and from Los
Angeles we have Jason Campania he's the
bureau chief for NBC News radio good day
to both of you Jason if we could start
with you
what do we know about the crash so far
right now it was a horrific crash and
the conditions were very foggy in
Southern California in the morning and
when the helicopter took off it was a
routine trip for Kobe Kobe used to take
helicopters to the Staples Center when
he was playing from his home in Orange
County about 40 miles away so this was
nothing out of the ordinary but what we
do know right now is that the plane or
the helicopter hit the hillside and then
burst into flames and the wreckage is
still smoldering as we speak right now
as far as what exactly happened in what
caused the helicopter to go down that is
yet to be determined but the government
is now launching a full investigation
okay you mentioned it was very usual for
Kobe dude to travel by helicopter where
was he going with his teenage daughter
on this particular flight so this
morning he was going to his Academy his
basketball camp if you will
it's a giant facility in northern Los
Angeles County and he was hosting a
tournament so basketball teams from all
across the country were there his
daughter was going to play in the
tournament today his team was against a
few other teams today and Kobe his
daughter and then a few other coaches
and their kids got in the same
helicopter and they perished as well
Alima this death the death of Kobe
Bryant is being marked around the world
what what made him such a giant in the
sport I mean I myself I'm still in a
sense of like distil a sense of
disbelief because I sat here in 2016
when he retired and I didn't expect four
years later I would be talking about his
tragic death
he was an inspiration to a lot of kids
to a lot of new generations he made a
lot of kids you know pick up a
basketball and there's a lot of players
and a lot of kids who you know still
always wanted to emulate his playing
style and he had a very odd journey as
well he's one of those few players that
went straight from high school to the
NBA so he didn't even go through college
and his achievements are just so long I
mean I don't even know where to begin he
was an exceptional leader he won five
NBA championships he was twice the the
most valuable player he won two Olympic
gold medals and he really was a giant of
the game he was a clutch player he was
able to finish a game I as a Toronto
Raptors fan remember really well in 2006
when Kobe Bryant single-handedly scored
81 points against the Toronto Raptors
that's the second highest ever in NBA
history and this is what Kobe was he
brought people to their feet
how else has America been responding to
the loss of one of its great sports
legends well people are flocking to
downtown Los Angeles and which the
Grammy is being held at Staples Center
Alicia Keys actually said we're sitting
in the house that Kobe built and I got
choked up when she said that you know
Kobe and I are the same age and I
watched him grow up and as a 17 year old
kid watching somebody your age hit the
NBA court it was it was amazing at the
time and people are going on social
media and posting pictures of when they
met them and they're running to Staples
Center to to greet ease with other fans
and just say you know we're here for you
Kobe and were your thoughts and prayers
are our thoughts and prayers are here
for you
Alima for all those people out there
we're seeing grieving right now how do
you think Kobe Bryant's going to be
remembered including by young people and
young athletes I think it was really an
he had specific characteristics about
him that made him so special and that
was he had to never give up attitude he
had a very strong work ethic ethic and
those are characteristics that are
applicable to all walks of life and you
know he really did transcend the game he
was a cultural icon a fashion icon and
you didn't even have to be a basketball
fan in order to know him Kobe for
example he also liked to ride he wrote
children's books on basketball he won an
Oscar for an animated short film that he
produced and he mentored a lot of NBA
players later in life and of course who
can forget also Kobe had has so many
famous quotes and I'm gonna leave you
with one it's a very motivational quote
and it sums up his competitive spirit
you have to keep moving smile just keep
on rolling Alima
thank you very much luma hotaki in the
studio and Jason camp adonia for us NBC
News radio in Los Angeles thank you very
much